many people ask me questions about stoic
philosophy and practice I've created
this series to provide short answers to
the most common recurring or confusing
questions about stoicism a common
challenge to stoicism particularly on
their views about nature and living in
accordance with nature stems from using
a passage from Friedrich Nietzsche's
Beyond Good and Evil and saying didn't
Nietzsche prove that the Stoics are
wrong the short answer to this question
is no Nietzsche did not prove that the
Stoics have nature or living in
accordance with nature wrong but there's
a lot more to say about the topic I
think that in a case like this it's very
helpful to look at what Nietzsche
actually says in this this passage which
is early on in beyond good and evil it's
section 9 of chapter 1 on the prejudices
of philosophers so here's what he
actually says you want to live according
to nature oh you noble Stoics what
fraudulent words think of a being such
as nature as prodigal beyond measure
indifferent beyond measure without aims
or intentions without mercy or justice
at once fruitful and bear it and
uncertain think of indifference itself
as a power how could you live according
to such indifference so that's one
important passage he continues to live
is this not precisely wanting to be
other than this nature is living not
valuating preferring being unjust being
limited wanting to be different and even
if your imperative live according to
nature men at bottom the same thing as
live according to life how could you not
do that why make a principle of what you
yourselves are and must be so that's
another important part of this passage
then he continues and says the truth of
it is however quite different while you
rapturously pose as deriving the Canon
of your law from nature you want
something quite the reverse of that you
strange actors and self deceivers your
pride wants to
prescribed your morality your ideal to
nature yes to nature itself and
incorporate them in it you demand that
nature should be nature according to the
stoah and would like to make all
existence exist only after your own
image as a tremendous eternal
glorification and universalization of
stoicism so these are some of the
criticisms that nietzsche is making in
that passage that people take as a
challenge to stoic doctrine now before
we consider each of these three points
in turn let's think for a moment about a
big assumption that people are making in
raising this very question does having a
criticism that some famous philosopher
gives of a particular doctrine
automatically mean that that doctrine is
thereby refuted nullified disproved the
answer is no because the person who's
making the criticism could actually be
off base or could be talking about
something quite different which happens
to be the case with this particular
passage so think about the first thing
that Nietzsche said in here he has a
very different conception of nature than
what the Stoics doing totally
understandable Nietzsche is coming from
very different philosophical basis he is
elaborating a very different
philosophical position so this is sort
of like somebody you know in one genre
of music saying wow you don't play it
all the way that I do his notion of
nature he says is a being that is
prodigal without measure and different
beyond measure without aims and
intentions without mercy or justice and
that just isn't what the Stoics are
calling nature so just saying I mean
this and you mean that therefore you're
wrong that's not a very good refutation
the second part of the passage makes two
interesting moves one is to say that
here's what living actually is and so
that has to be the opposite of nature of
course notice nature as I need to have
understood it and articulated it to you
so as so it could just say well I don't
agree with what you think nature is then
he says what you Stoics are saying is
really just vacuous I mean if you if you
mean you know living in accordance with
life how can you not do that everybody's
doing that already so you're really just
uttering a truism or a tautology that
doesn't mean anything
and again you have to ask yourself is is
that what the Stoics actually mean or is
nietzsche caricaturing them his third
criticism I think really gets to the
heart of the matter he is saying listen
you Stoics I know that that you have a
different conception of nature than I do
I whom I'm actually right about it and
what you're doing is kind of
intellectual sleight of hand you're
reading into nature what it is that
you're wanting to find in nature and
then surprise surprise you actually do
find it so what you're doing is in
essence just assuming it's like a
circular form of reasoning or if you
like of inquiry and again you have to
ask yourself is nietzsche actually you
know depicting the Stoics in a fair
light here I think just a brief reading
of stoic text shows that Nietzsche is
actually off base on this one there may
be criticisms that one can give of
stoicism and of certain assumptions that
they're making but this isn't it
as a last note I'd like to say we can
generalize this a little bit further
it's not just about Nietzsche and the
Stoics and this particular passage
anytime that you're bringing up somebody
who is criticizing somebody else you
want to make sure that the criticism is
in fact on base they're not attributing
to those other people something that
they're not saying they are criticizing
them for things that you know you don't
have to automatically buy into their
system in order to say that makes sense
and that isn't the case here and that
isn't the case with many of the
criticisms not only of stoicism but
other philosophical positions you want
to be very careful in adopting other
philosophers critical assessments of
people whose philosophical basis systems
and orientations they do not share if
you found this answer helpful for you
then please share it with others who
might benefit from it this work is
entirely supported by crowdfunding on my
patreon site so if you find it valuable
consider becoming a supporter at
patreon.com slash Saddler